I've held two coding jobs so far and
they were both very very different so
the first one I had I was still in
school and I got a job at a biology lab
doing some day of data science stuff and
helping with a project that
well I would go to many details but
he basically analyzed
gene sequence stuff so worked on that it
wasn't there wasn't much C or C++
involved it was mostly Perl and that was
by choice of the original developer so
that was a pretty interesting job but it
was a student job so it didn't pay much
it was very very challenging like but
also one of the interesting things about
that job was I had to make it happen
there was there was no one that
approached me and said hey do you want a
job and even when I got the job the guy
was a little the guy was a little
hesitant about let me jump right into
code and right into the to the meat
potatoes of it of the project and I'm
sure he had his reasons
but I think what he wanted to see was a
level of interest because at first it
was like okay I'm going to introduce you
to this biology lab I'll show you what
we do have you worked with
the other guys and I was doing that and
it was it was not it was not my cup of
tea like I didn't
I didn't really care I was just like all
right so you're doing some research
taking some pictures mixing some things
going over the proper storage methods
and gather data and I was just thinking
the whole time like
I'm not interested in this it's just all
going to be doing I should just walk out
now because this is this is me although
it was pretty interesting
it was it was nice to meet the new
people so our main flight were being
bored
showed up and did what I could that sort
of thing but at some point after a while
I just went to my boss and I was like
look one can I get involved in this code
stuff that's that's what I'm really here
for
and I just straight-up said it like that
and he was just like no
so I think it clicked to him at that
point that I wasn't really interested in
anything other than getting involved in
the software stuff and things changed
just from that that that quick couple
sentences I said after you know I did
I didn't immediately go into the lab and
be like alright give me the code I kind
of let him feel it out and I think that
made him more comfortable with me maybe
I could I don't know I think I played it
ok overall but it was able to be a
little tricky it wasn't it wasn't just
the easiest thing to
to dive into I mean this was in a way
this was like his last ten years work in
a piece of software and to just let some
guy he doesn't know very well dive in
and have at it I don't think it was
super comfortable with that until he got
to know me a little better
know that I was you know gonna be
dedicated basically and almost
immediately he's like okay I got it
that's what you want to do it's what
you're interested in
and he started setting me up with this
stuff it's like okay we're setting you
access to this here's how you get to
that it's like oh I'll take it from here
I'm sure we'll have a lot of questions
for you we'll take a lot of all that
you know it was
I didn't really know how I would go
every job is different every person runs
any job is different
but it was a very open job and
I was working on it quite a bit for the
first month
but I got to the point where I started
feeling really drained I was basically
working on the same thing I was getting
stuck a lot and without going into too
many details I'll say it was extremely
hard and not just because I'd never used
pearl before coral wasn't too bad to
learn they picked up pearl
easily quickly I'm not an expert in it
but I mean I competed modified
you know that's that's the thing once
you once you learn how to code in one
environment you can sort of figure out
other environments way quicker than you
could before it's just getting really
good at the first one that takes time so
it's it's worth it to stick with one
until you get really good at it
rather than bounce around to be bounced
around a lot it's gonna be a slower
learning curve so parole wasn't that bad
just because I drove so much into C++ so
I had that requisite algorithm knowledge
bring it
buddy got to the point where
the guy who originally wrote this he was
writing it on his own accord it wasn't a
train software developer or anything he
was doing it to just process data so it
was a big data processing structure it's
a pretty big deal it's very cool it's
one of those things that could make a
difference in the world
just based on what I did so I was pretty
motivated just by that was like okay
this
something useful that's great so month
goes by I'm working on it documenting
and figuring out how everything goes and
making improvements in the structure my
overall goal was to make it usable by
anyone because the way it was it was
basically only usable by the person who
wrote it because there wasn't really any
instructions you just kind of had to
figure it out so that's what I did I
basically figured it out passed a lot of
questions documented everything made up
nice little documents
I changed the structure I've heard the
flow I changed the way it handled a lot
of the includes and you know just like
libraries and stuff trying to make a lot
of improvements there
I wrote very careful instructions about
how a user or a new user should acquire
the data required to start running a new
batch of new data set and that wasn't
easy to figure out because it basically
it wasn't documented and I guess there
was a student that worked on it before
me and he seemed like he was ok but
after observing his work and comparing
it to where it was the project was
before he came in I basically came to
the conclusion that he kind of gave up
he went to the point where he was just
like he was grabbing tools from the
internet to run analysis on the code
and that's where he was so it wasn't
really like modifying the code and
trying to figure it out anymore it was
just like a screw and I'm just gonna
front some stuff to make it look like
I'm doing something so he's running like
I don't know just flint tools and stuff
on it which you know that's it has its
use but I think
it wasn't really doing much for the
actual program to advance it anymore and
maybe that's why he left when he didn't
get fired I think he actually he
actually left and I think he left just
graduated and moving on to new job a
real job not a student job so
it wasn't any red flags or anything
there but I did get
feeling that it was hard this was
clearly a hard job
and I was definitely challenged so I I
really liked all that about it that was
that was cool so anyway I keep getting
sidetracked here
but the month goes by I'm not feeling
very motivated to work on a much more
I've done the big pieces documented and
restructured it feels pretty usable to a
new guy coming in I think but I need
some other people to test it and fresh
set of eyes on it basically I need
someone else to try from scratch
and that's kind of where it was or what
it didn't feel like there's a whole lot
I can do I was just kind of poking
around at it and like I don't know what
the nudist so
some of the next goals were basically to
write a manuscript on the whole thing
and I was like whoa I didn't feel
qualified to do it because the
underlying algorithm of what it did
exactly I didn't fully understand I'm
not a biologist and there were a lot of
a lot of biological terms in there that
things about DNA and sequencing that I
didn't exactly know what they meant so
I'd have to constantly look them up and
then there are so many acronyms and
counts they have to look them up I
didn't I just didn't feel like I had the
the I don't know the requisite knowledge
to write a manuscript a little thing I
was like sure I can make the document
how runs and the general results it
gives in generalities but I can't tell
you specifics of what it's doing to the
DNA
I can just give generalities so I didn't
know how to really explain that to my
boss other than the way I just explained
it to you and he didn't really like that
explanation which is understandable he
like I think he understood but his
mindset was like okay we'll go learn it
and I was like okay I'm trying it's a
lot of stuff
I mean I've taken two biology classes
and I've got this book here that I'm
going through daily I'm looking up stuff
daily but there's just so much you know
this is like a career lifelong
profession to learn all this stuff
that's just not my interest I don't want
to be a biologist so I made the decision
that I have to be
and I have to do something else because
I didn't want to keep going that same
direction
and it was it was tough but ultimately I
just I just wrote up an email and I said
look my interests are more aligned with
software development and I see that what
I have to dive really deep into biology
here if I want to continue and I think
I'm just going to go the software
development route I was very open about
that stuff let him know look my
long-term goals to be game developer
told them that I was basically really
happy to be part of what I was part of
and you have to leave this job in the
lab
move on to the next thing and he was
just like his immediate response was no
no no no no please don't leave I need
you and that was just like okay
so that made it hard to leave because he
was like no totally and I kind of poked
around for another couple months I
didn't get very many hours although I
was given complete freedom basically
just like look
looks like look there's keys lad and go
whenever you need you can work the poem
if you want just [ __ ] your hours it's
fine it was very open like that and that
that made it all so hard to leave
because I was cool but the underlying
problem was I didn't have the motivation
to keep pursuing deeper into biology and
I thought maybe at a later date but I'm
still still in my head I want to go
towards game development so the dad
decision didn't change that wasn't going
to change no matter how good everything
else sound him and yeah I stuck around
for another semester but when I
graduated I also left the lab and I
you know I clock like 10 hours a week at
that point why I was in my last three
months
this was our after I already said I was
going to leave
I basically stuck around attended
convenience did some little stuff I also
helped there a new guy got hired and I
helped the new guy get appointed to the
program
everything so I did a little bit of
training for the new guy that was I
think was essentially going to replace
me although I don't think he could
replace me not to sound like I'm
bragging or anything just because
he wasn't as insane as I was basically
like when I get into a project I become
insane about it all obsessed focus just
go all out until it works like I wanted
and not very many people have that and I
think that's a quality of insanity so
this guy was more normal than me so I
don't think he was gonna be able to jump
in the project like I did based on that
well that I don't know how that's gonna
sound later when I was back to it yeah
that's that's basically my personality
is I've become very obsessed over my
projects and that that has its benefits
and its downsides
[Music]
I don't know if I want to get into all
that basically the downside of that is
eventually you have a million projects
you don't have time for them all that's
that's where I'm at now so I'm trying to
pick and choose a little better and do
you think why I can one of the reasons I
do videos in the car like this is
because this is what I have just
complete downtime where I can't work on
any of my projects and basically just
stuck in a car for hours driving
and nothing else for me to do so it's
like I got to do something don't record
a video talk about that sorry that works
for me
at all I don't do videos softer because
I'm often just to fall and something
already I don't feel like stopping get
into the video money too
then also I feel like I'm at home I have
plenty of time to prepare and do this
video better than I went too far but at
the cars just like I cling it means guys
can see the sky and background anyway
alright so I leave that job I graduate
and
I I applied to some companies that I
wanted to be a part of all gaming
companies I applied to whispers the
coast or Hasbro I applied to a few other
gaming companies and I updated my resume
and everything on Monster Careerbuilder
which is scary I don't know if I'd
recommend doing that honestly I mean if
you just need a job and don't feel like
looking it's a good thing to do but
basically what happens when you update
your resume on career builder or monster
or any of those sites is recruiters see
that you recently updated your your
resume and they start calling you give
me a job opportunities we're trying to
set you up something to them you know
that's their job it's now blowing you up
people have a lot of mixed feelings
about recruiters some people hate him
for some people
overall my experience with the recruiter
is good and the reason that I'm talking
about this at all is because
I've gotten a lot of my professional
experience because I've worked with
recruiters sure I could go apply to jobs
individually but and I'm always like
involved in something else
so I rarely applied to a job and less
than something I really want I'm just
gonna go apply to a bunch of banks or
dig around looking for jobs all day I
just like if I see a company I really
like help like and that's that's
basically it but otherwise I just all
update my resume and stuff on there and
computers will call and offer me stuff
and a lot of times a lot of times I'll
just say I'm not too interested or just
too far away or I can't believe okay at
this time occasionally something comes
up where it's like okay that sounds
great you know go the whole nine yards
[Music]
and if job sounds good I'll take him so
that's how I got my current job doing
C++ after a month or two of being
graduated and kind of hanging around
wait and waiting for a good opportunity
that's so wait I mean it did apply to
stuff but I needed a job and remember
what I did for a couple months took a
couple months now
I think I mainly worked on my game
engine thing the Walmart truck
well anyway so I get this job through a
recruiter with a with a company Julie
just you know the job specifically said
will C++ software development it was
like perfect that's all I want to do you
try to throw me on another language I'm
not really that interested I want to get
better at C++ because I want to be a
game developer and I was very I'm very
open about that even the job interviews
they say okay so this job had nothing to
do with game development really other
than it working for lot of math which
was like perfect practice my Sifu plus
use math to you know practice that
that's gonna be very useful game
development everything about this job
would basically advance my skills as a
game developer so I was like because
perfect I want this job I knew what this
job does negotiate all don't do whatever
I can to make sure I get it dressed to
impress whatever I don't care I have
with this job I'm not getting any game
bill for once this well let's face it I
don't have any games under my belt and
that's what almost every big company
wants they say you need at least two or
three releases and
we consider you fair enough I understand
so I'm not getting any of those big jobs
but I could get this one just based on
my C++ skill alone so let's take it from
the top I scheduled the first interview
and flood happens there was a flood at
my current residence and I couldn't make
the interview and I was like oh god this
is gonna ruin my chances of very like
nervous about it's like you know I
called everyone I could recruit her the
person I was supposed to have the
interview with I was like look I'm sorry
I can't make the interview there's a big
flood going on in my house that I have
to deal with and I'm kind of in a pickle
here and they're like okay no problem
we'll reschedule I was like ah I was
thinking I really hope this doesn't hurt
my chances and ultimately it didn't
because I did the interview later and
they went pretty well I was a little
nervous about it not that nervous though
I don't get that nervous in interviews
not anymore
even if I'm doing bad an interview I
don't get that nervous I don't know why
maybe I've just done enough but I think
that kind of shows through a little bit
science or whatever people don't like
being around really nervous people makes
them uncomfortable and nervous too so I
think that helped but the coding
question they gave me was like really
easy to be I was like yes give me
something I could handle like no problem
and you know they could've gave me
something really hard and maybe you know
thinking back on this question would
probably be really hard to a lot of
people but it's just something I had
done so much already that I was like oh
yeah
get the thing they ask me a lot of other
questions to like what I have
experienced with every use this I've
ever used that and
I answered them all as honestly as I
could I didn't try to talk up my skills
any more than what my stuff showed you
know I have I have a giant github
account with like 70 things on it so I
think that helped I think they were just
overwhelmed when they looked at my
github account there's so much stuff
yeah there's a couple programs on there
that have a decent amount of stars from
the community so I think that helped and
one of them is based on DD of this
little DD app thing they've been working
on and I think they really like that
because I guess a couple people at the
company played D&D and when they got a
cool
you fit right in that helped so
ultimately I got the job I was I was
nervous that I wouldn't but I got the
callback they're like okay yeah we'd
like Dyer
great so I'm hired through a recruiter
I'm a contractor
I don't mind being a contractor the pace
towed well enough hey I'm having a hard
time getting 40 hours every week because
well driving is a big thing and it's
really hard to code for eight hours a
day just the same right now most people
can only do four to six hours of coding
and I find I'm about the same once I hit
like hour seven or our date I do not
feel effective anymore I can kind of
poke around and get through things but
it's very slow with a lot of mistakes
and yeah you should just stop after six
hours especially if you're not feeling
it go do something else go rest plan
whatever you know it's a pretty big deal
really it took me a while to figure that
out because I was trying to do 10-hour
for tens for a while and that didn't
work so well I was feeling really bad at
the end of every day when I'm doing 10
hours and my boss had some concern she
was like look things aren't going quite
as well as I expected
like how fast you're producing code and
stuff and I was like yeah
I feel that too yeah we kind of just
leveled and I was like all right look
I've realized some things I need to
adjust my schedule I can undo these ten
hours I've just completely useless after
a few hours and I basically basically
feel like I'm wasting company time and
it feels really bad to me too so I don't
want to do that I need to figure out a
better way to be productive while I'm
here and you know we just had some
discussions like that I really had to
come down on myself and be like
look
eat your head stream that was really
important and things are going better
now but that really took me like a month
or two to to sort out I was really
having such a rough time because playing
the hours I was trying to do this not
working for me but I was also trying to
get enough hours and I thought oh if I
don't get enough hours they're gonna be
upset that I'm not getting enough hours
but they're a really cool company
they're more about results and anything
else so it's like what wouldn't care
buddy our together it's just a matter of
getting the project I mean if we get it
done quicker that's great you know cos
that's last week too painless but at the
same time it's also important to get it
done right and everybody works at a
different pace you'll get faster as you
get more used to libraries we get all
that
and you know so couple more months have
gone by and things have definitely
improved I feel way better way more
comfortable I basically can see it that
I'm gonna work the hours I feel
comfortable working and that's does it
and they're cool with that too stuff
yeah I have learned a lot doing this job
a lot about myself about what it takes
to be a professional coder about using
your time effectively
that wouldn't change it
however if they're welcome a time where
I have to leave because well my
interests are still with game
development and I've been very open
about that to my boss too
I said I don't plan on staying here
forever I stay as long as I can and
getting as much space as I can one day
I'm gonna move on to game 2 though
Triple A games my long-term goal that
gives me the daily motivation
all right well thanks for watching this
video that's that's what my career's
been like so far and I'll catch you guys
in the next one ever could want